I know you guys had Tate on yeah and you
know he's now home uh home confinement
right in Romania I've been reaching out
we've been reaching out to his team for
a couple of weeks right before the
arrest happened because we weren't we
want to have him on it's funny because I
was like it's like look like this guy
says really interesting stuff I know
he's controversial and all that stuff
and obviously he's facing these charges
now but clay and I talked about it we
hadn't you know brought it up before I
looked at him I'm like like I see this
guy on Tick Tock I think we should have
him on the show I think it's really
interesting some of the stuff that he's
saying and he's like he's like he's my
son's favorite my two oldest boys every
now and then I'll go and I'll say like
hey because I mentioned they're on
YouTube they're on wait hold your boys
by the way uh 15 12 and eight okay so
the two teenagers oh yeah the two oldest
I said hey if I could have anybody on
the radio show who would you like me to
have on and they both instantaneously
said Andrew Tate and then Buck brought
him up like the next you know two or
three days later happenstance yeah but I
think it speaks to there's a lot of boys
out there and we've talked about this on
our show that feel lost in this sort of
toxic masculinity era and so they're
looking for that's why I mentioned
coaches earlier but that masculine
influence who can tell teach them how to
be men and I feel like his individual
like hey just go do more push-ups uh and
stop being a [__] like that actually
connects a lot you guys remember with 13
14 15 year old boys yeah there's no
question about it I asked the question
when I said like who's the audience when
people come in they'll talk to me I'll
say so how do you know about us and what
we do oh I watch Valium all the time I
said do you watch the podcast or just by
attainment which podcast okay great so
you're more to entertainment audience
how about yourself you know I I watch
the podcast and I listen you know
through Spotify okay so Spotify
interesting audience what do you do for
I want to know what the background of
these guys are yeah Tick Tock if I go to
school with my kids their kids well
their friends will stop by because
they're Tick Tock audience right snap
audience I can't really find a Snapchat
audience there's Instagram there's you
YouTube there's Spotify there's you know
Tick Tock but it's different if I go on
Fox and I see who stops me I'm on a Dan
bongino show and next thing you know the
following day hey you know I saw you
yesterday on the damn bongino show so
okay that makes sense older crowd yeah
it's a very different crowd but the the
thing when you're
starting out I think is you gotta when
you're newer not you guys you guys you
guys are at this point your vets you're
running the show with the biggest
eyeballs you took a spot that everybody
went everybody was fighting for that
spot I remember the whole talk was this
guy's gonna get it is he going to get it
is that going to get it no way thank God
that's insane right everybody was
talking about that slot but uh you when
you start out it's important to have a
very Niche audience to start off with
and then gradually as you go wider and
you talk other opinions people say damn
you actually can talk about that stuff
can we hear more things like that kind
of like what you were talking about
earlier so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]